I mean my story for that gig's a little
different though because my band was
called V5 we had the five coolest hair
dudes in
Toronto yeah this and our logo I steamed
off the V5 shampoo bottle and that was
our logo V5 yeah we only did two shows
it wasn't a big bad but one of the shows
Nikki and Tommy came it was the night
before that gig and Nikki and Tommy came
to our gig at Rock and Roll Heaven down
town across from Harvey's on
blur right at near the corner of young
and blur you used to walk down them
stairs and there was this club there I
don't know if you were old enough to get
in no no no I was 13 okay on that day
yeah okay so so Nikki and Tommy came and
everybody goes to me hey man
Nikki and Tommy are here and they're
looking for the best blow in to and I'm
like
hello I'm the singer of the band for
sakes and they're like right this way
singer of band I guess who had the best
blow in
to that was me man and they were my best
buddies that night tomby and Nikki we
were
[__] do
somea shffle snacks some some beer SAS
and uh and they're like you're coming
backstage tomorrow I go yeah I am you
better believe it I was like the best
did you bring blow backstage the next
night yes I did and I brought black hash
and I was smoking it in the backstage
room and Fred Saunders said hey hey
please don't don't smoke Ash backstage
and I was like [__] it's Molly Crew like
dude how about that show how about that
show when that was the 80s by the way I
have to say for all these people
listening the uh the this was the girls
girls girls tour 87 of
1987 and this was the tour when Tommy
Lee's drum set came up over the crowd
and then rotated upside down I have a
funny story about that too and at the
beginning of that drum solo there was
like all right you know Vince Vince says
you want to have a drink with the crew
Tonto yes and uh so then like Nikki 6
like brings a bottle of Jack Daniels
he's like all right we're gonna and
Nikki like pours he's like sprays the
crowd with them with the Jack Daniels so
that they can like tell it's real
whiskey they're not like you know it's
it's not fake and then so now it's like
cheers to the crowd we're going to have
a drink and Nikki like just puts the
bottle up upside down just chugging and
on each chug Tommy Lee
like like timing the chugs with like
drum beats boom boom they're putting
down a fifth putting just chugging
whiskey and that's how and that's how
the drum solo started
boom you know and that like what an epic
way to start a drum solo well I have a
couple of comments to that is the the
tour before two tours before cuz there
was theater of pain and I went to that I
went to in Toronto and then me and my
buddies got in our car and drove to
Ottawa and watched it again um and but
the tour before that the first time
Molly Crew played Toronto was Shout at
the Devil so they would have been
opening for aie no except was opening
for them they were headlining at the
little tiny CN grand stand Arena which
was like 4,000 Cedar so we were so
freaked out that mly crew is headl in in
Toronto and the shout of the devil to
herself we got a bunch of mushrooms and
went and stayed overnight in the line
like we got there at like 6:00
p.m. and I was like 14 nice and doing
shrooms okay now this is in Nikki's
book which one I mean he what it like
book four now or something yeah well so
this was in the book we woke up and we
didn't really sleep obviously right we
thought it was a great idea and [__]
we're all whacked out and up on shrooms
and [__] and we're right at the very
very front in fact me and my buddies are
smushed up against like the glass like
this like like this
like and all these croutons are behind
us pushing and this guy this crazy guy
next to me with no shirt on and [__] and
he was all drunk and everything and he
goes this [__] he goes we're not stay in
here and he turns around and he this is
all true he kicks the glass out of the
front of the CN grand stand doors and I
go and we bend down and the whole crowd
runs in wow and there was like a
thousand kids and we rushed the stage I
remember this like yesterday and the
crews on the stage and they back they go
whoa whoa and we get right to the front
we go crew crew crew crew crew and it
was like
2m and they're trying to set up Sound
Check Yes and Nikki remembers as they
had to pay he goes that was you I go
well it was a guy next to me but I was
the first one in and they had to pay for
all the new doors and [__] the cops came
yes the cops came in and said get the
out of here and we were all scared we're
going to get arrested and that was fun
times Jesus wow shout of the devil yeah
but that was good that was a different
time like if any of my kids are watching
this like I don't
do I mean dude what a dude the 80s man I
and then wait there's another s there's
another story when you talk
about Tommy's Drum Kit revolving yeah
yeah um we my we opened every show on
the do field good tour with Skid Row in
89 in Europe the whole tour uhhuh and I
had a
little thinging with uh Christina
Applegate um oh wow I don't know if you
know her story when she goes I left Brad
Pit one night for some guy and I'm not
gonna even say who it was
hello that would be me that was her with
the children days that was the MTV
Awards that night and she came with Brad
Pit and left with me mother
druger wow Sor so I fly her to Paris to
see me play with mle Gro and her mom
comes and her aunt comes and we go to
the Eiffel Tower we go to dinner and all
this stuff so at the mle Cru
show going up and standing right side
stage and Nikki goes hey he standing up
on the top thing and I'm like hey man
because I was like I didn't want to be
like you know the guying the [__] up on
the stage yeah so so I go we better move
you know like so we walk across and
Tommy Tommy's Drum goes up and starts
turning and then it stops and he's stuck
and I thought I [__] unplugged his
drum kit like oh holy we got to get the
out of here because we I was walking
right there and then it stopped and he's
like hanging upside down in France and I
go oh my God I unplugged his drums and
the the show's wrecked and I it was AED
up night he was like hanging upside down
cuz he wanted a key bump he was just
waiting for you to but I thought I
kicked out the cord Tom you know and
he's upside down and I was like must did
Tommy tell us about how uh his his drum
text would like come
and oh and just shovel it into his nose
yeah that was uh was it like they were
like all he used to do that was Some
Guns and Roses guys they did like said
like was like bottle caps full oh my God
bottle cap yeah do you like shopping on
Amazon I do and good news is sto's butt
wipes for your butthole are available on
Amazon and if you want a real bundle of
a deal you can get sto's hot sauce for
your butthole plus sto's butthole
destroyer and steo butt wipes for your
butthole it's the butthole bundle
available on Amazon right
now yeah dude